hey guys it's evan caitlin podcast the
show that does not judge you whether you
are or aren't wearing pants right now
and you don't even know we are aren't
wearing pants right don't look alright
so what are we gonna be covering in this
episode so we're gonna talk a little bit
about how we met because that was one of
the things requested recently and we're
gonna I think segue from that into some
of the early DIY projects we attempted I
mean if we end up talking about how we
met four super long will we'll save that
other one for another day yeah maybe
like some of the highs and some of the
lows and then we're gonna play again if
we have time a fun music related I'm
gonna be really good I think you're
gonna be really bad that's a good reason
to be excited but I agree I wouldn't be
bad I mean I'm gonna do pretty well I
didn't you should be able to get the
ones like thanks for having mercy on me
okay so so the how we met story it's
interesting because we like we met just
casually as friends so like the first
time we met we don't really remember
what it was
no I have a pretty strong impression
about like I've too strong impression
yeah I agree I agree so the story that I
think that's been in our heads for the
longest is we met the first day of class
freshman year of college in calculus 2
which I was really impressed with
because Katelyn didn't even need to take
it oh I just took it cuz I was like well
I had taken calc 1 senior year of high
school couch she was like the next thing
you take I didn't think about the fact
that I was a business major and I wasn't
required I was just like well I did calc
one last year so this is the next two
math like that was like Caitlin's
science credit and she could have taken
like no it was like an elective like
river water the night
calc two is an elective oh I had a lot
of respect for you but I think that we
were talking with one of our friends
we're talking with my roommate yeah
College and she was like that's not how
you guys met I've been fixed your
computer and I was like oh yeah I know
he fixed it but she was like yeah think
about it
that was before class cuz so you know at
school you all you had to get your
laptop set up on the school network and
this and that and I had an apple and
there weren't many people with Apple
computers and so like the instructions
weren't as good and I couldn't figure
button with with all of the students
coming in the first day it's not like
the IT staff could really help everybody
so I was just helping out just because I
wanted to help out I don't even know how
I found you I think I was just like
waiting in line and you saw that I had a
Mac and you were like oh I was having a
lot of people and I think that that I
mean funnily enough I later on started
working for the IT department at our
College in Decatur but I just knew how
to do it well I guess you had already
been at school because you were an RA
no that's freshman year I wasn't an all
right the first year as a freshman yeah
[Laughter]
we had a calculus and English together
mm-hmm
which is like we weren't in the same
major so I feel like we're pretty lucky
to have two classes together
fresh like our first semester freshman
and I I immediately thought that Jalen
was super cool I actually had a little
bit of a crush on her right away
and I let our Alan found out that she
was dating someone and I did not like
the guy for some strange reason I don't
know completely clueless about your
crush freshman year yeah but then we
just became friends and we had projects
together well oh yeah we did a video oh
my gosh guys Matt found the video where
do we find it my shooters oh man why is
gone now us and one or two other people
imagine like how bad you think it is and
it's way worse
it's it's pretty bad I think we were
stopped we were I remember like my role
in one of the scenes there were two
things that I had to do I don't know
what anyone else had to do but the two
things I had to do if there's one and we
were talking about like freshmen life or
something yeah and there was one where I
was furiously and stressfully pretending
to write and I was so stressed out and I
just couldn't oh my god if you if you're
watching the video or if you know I see
the fear right now I'm reenacting and
it's very good acting very good and then
there's another scene where I pretended
to like get in a fight with my roommate
yeah about clothes or something it's
just twitch notification comin on the
computer thank you I just followed um
yes that's all I remember do you
remember your parts of it at all I don't
I think that not not to like it feels we
were saying this but I think that the
one where you were fighting it's because
you were like jealous of you I was the
boyfriend and I was jealous I know
so I was a freshman year first semester
and and then you you have idea we were
picking classes and you found
dance yeah well I really wanted to take
a ballroom dance class which was random
anyway because I never really had any
desire to learn how to dance but it was
just like a bunch of calculus credit
you're like nope no homework super
awkward and like the thought of just
being randomly paired with some guy that
I didn't know was like like induced the
worst kind of anxiety in me so I was
like hey Evan do you want to take this
ballroom dance super and no and you're
like yeah and as an engineer they're
like an easy credit just seems like a
good choice you know what like
everything else had
much homework it was a lot worth it
worth it I mean worth it so we we took
ballroom dance and we have so much fun
we did it again and then later on we T
ate it twice there are only there's only
ballroom one in ballroom two and then
like you couldn't keep taking the same
class country-western or something but
we were like now ballrooms fun yeah and
it was kind of the same dances anyway
just like slightly tweaked but we were
like oh will just become TAS and TA it
was like hung out and danced and like
every time the class would take an exam
we would play Mario Kart on your tiny
computer a low powered netbook and I
loved that thing oh my god there's once
when the students were taking an exam
and we were just we were like sitting
against the back wall playing Mario Kart
and then we looked up and it was empty
like everyone had last yeah we were like
how long have we been here did no one
tell us the class is over and then
that's like I don't know if you have
this this like reoccurring not nightmare
but like do you ever have this nightmare
where like you have a class that you
didn't know about and you haven't been
taking like looking for my schedule for
everybody and it's I didn't even like
like I never accidentally missed a class
or anything it's not like it happened
does everyone have nightmares about like
missing class there's that justice I
mean I think like school relate like not
being prepared for school in general and
some capacity is pretty common me it was
like missing it was it was specifically
finding out that I had a class I didn't
know about yeah I remember you hadn't
been going to it the whole semester oh
gosh or I show up the first day and I
feel like yeah super beard first day
school you know and I'm like really
excited and then I realized I don't know
where any of my classes are I don't know
any of the classes I'm taking it don't
anything my teacher if I don't have my
schedule same nightmare really maybe is
it cuz we moved so much
maybe because like things did change a
lot I think seems a lot
different places different systems yeah
okay we got sidetracked where were we oh
okay okay so so so we were taking dance
classes together yeah and we were just
friends and then junior year I didn't
know this at all in the moment yeah jump
ahead at that point if you want to I
didn't know if you want to talk about
sophomore year Oh
sophomore year yeah so okay so sophomore
year we were both just friends at this
point the first time that we were both
single cuz I had broken up with my
boyfriend and I very smoothly asked
Kailyn out on a date via text except it
was not smooth at all it was it was baby
was it did she write it on my facebook
wall so it was vague like it wasn't
obviously a date but I think like I
don't even know how I would have reacted
if it was because I was so so awkward
about boys stuff but I didn't know that
I thought like oh you're just so cool no
I was in college still awkward about
boys are you read the text Anita's got
sweaty nervous because I was like well I
might be reading it wrong and then I'm
getting all freaked out over nothing and
I don't know so she turned me down I
said I had to do homework Kaitlyn does
her homework like way in advance I know
you're on top of things
waited until the last minute with my
homework what you shouldn't do anyone
still in school yes what have we been
dating from that point onward I know
that would have been cool IIIi think of
that too but at the same time all of the
life experiences that we went through
like before we started dating that
helped shape who we were and I love who
we are now yeah and it's hard to be able
to like go back and cherry-pick what you
might want to change and you don't know
how that would change your life yeah I
know it's tough yeah so in the end
everything worked out but I I have that
thought too it's like whatever you could
go back and you could change this or
that but then it goes into light but
then you change everything potentially
you know butterfly effect yeah exactly
yeah I know I'm like logically I'm like
yeah okay that makes sense yeah I'm
trying to pull you closer right you
always end up like bumping each other at
frame with our chairs no I'm trying to
say back so you have enough room to like
come in and everything I'm fully in
frame look at me look at my yeah okay
for everyone listening to just about
audio it was you tell that sorry cuz
that's your story to tell yeah well
junior year it was the first time I
guess well I'll just go into a junior
year as when I had a crush on you mhm
and you were dating someone else by that
point and I think you were pretty
oblivious to I've gotten like like now
they told me no people told me I was
like I was purposely not flirting with
you I was trying not to because like you
had already been in your relationship
for a while at that point like it was
like a year already and you know I was
very like I was like I like him but
we've been friends for a long time and
you know this will probably pass and
like he's been in a relationship for a
year and like that's not something I
want to risk messing up although I will
say that one time we went out mm-hmm
like we like went out to grab drinks
with another friend like I definitely
was flirting with you still oblivious
and very friendly guy I took your watch
and I put it on my arm duh who will do
that unless you're interested
someone I wore your watch I I stole your
watch duh like you I guess he likes my
watch I did feel bad for the other
friend though that we've always had a
very easy conversational flow with each
other we liked similar TV shows we liked
all sorts of things I mean freshman year
we were talking about fooly cooly which
is like somewhat I don't I don't want to
call him scared because there's a lot
probably even more obscure enemies but
well back then it might have been more
obscure yeah yeah yeah we're time am I
in my room it was like Miriam yeah
because we've always just talked really
easily with each other been really open
with each other and just been good
friends so I think that like the friend
that we went out with wasn't as good
friends with either of us so mainly the
two of us talking yeah but so that was
junior year and then that's really all
to share for junior senior year nothing
yeah well senior year we were both
dating on the same person and I was
dating ironically the same person I was
freshman yeah I know I know and then but
we are still taking dance class we're
still hanging out and then when we
graduated you moved to Houston yep I was
in San Antonio and we ended up I mean
and we we like chatted a lot in college
like we do is grab lunch every pretty
much every other day because we have
lunch after our classes after ballroom
and but like after we graduated I almost
feel like we start chatting even more
like via text at least yeah I mean maybe
not more but like we we kept in touch
like a lot because we chatted pretty
much every day we were both at jobs that
were kind of slow and kind of too easy
yeah so we were just like google chat
each other literally all day every day
yeah that that job that job I mean like
see that's what you get when you don't
have in-house manufacturing you have to
sent things out and there's a long
turnaround and your engineers are just
sitting there not you being utilized to
their full potential
okay I got distracted it wasn't okay
moving on
so eventually we both broke up with the
people that we're dating
just they weren't the right people for
us and we we finally saw that and then
well and I'll add to this before we go
to the next part that like we were each
other's go-to person for relationship
issues so like if Evan was having
relationship trouble
I was his like like female perspective
advice and when I was having
relationship self trouble Evan was my
male perspective advice so we were
always talking to each other about like
you know getting relationship advice and
stuff because it's confusing yeah yeah
yeah it's confusing especially like
earlier on you know yeah but so about a
year after graduation we had a mutual
friend who was having a birthday um in
San Antonio and I was like hey you
should come we haven't hung out since
graduation I was like hey you should
come and Surprise them it'll be fun
while hang out and so you came we had
like an awesome time but preface this so
we were both single we had told our
families and friends all right we are
gonna be single for a while we just like
yeah because it was like relatively long
term ish really I mean specially for you
long-term relationships we're like we're
just gonna be single we're gonna figure
out our lives we're gonna figure out
like I know things people do in their
single right yeah like so you came to
hang out that weekend and we had a
really good time and then you came the
next weekend I think you came to Mexico
so the first weekend I went up there and
I had such a fun time and hang out with
all of your friends up there too right
yeah yeah and it was so fun and you and
a friend came and visited me in Houston
and now so much fun and then we just
started hang out a lot yeah like
literally every weekend and then like I
forget what it was but I think that for
me the first time I noticed I definitely
had a crush on you
is it was like a big group of friends
like 10 people and I wanted to sit next
to you like while we were watching is
Tron or something like that and we're at
we're at your friend's house and Tron
was on and I wanted to sit next to you
and then I
wasn't sitting next to you and that
upset me more than was reasonable I was
like why is this so setting I realize
that's when I had a crush on here like I
wanted I just wanna sit next to you you
know it's weird it's like I had my
realization in a very similar situation
we were watching a movie with a group of
friends
it wasn't Tron because that was at a
friend's house it was at your apartment
so as one of the times that we were
visiting but before we had told each
other we liked each other
see I we haven't fully compared notes I
wonder who got the crush on the other
person first it seemed like it was very
much a dissimilar tapas yeah I think it
was like a similar timeline but like I
just realized there was like for a
little bit and we might not have been
watching a movie it might not have been
just during the movie but it was like
wherever you were that's what I wanted
to be it's like when we watch the movie
I wanted to be next to you like if
you're sitting on the floor I wanted to
be next to you yeah like I just like
wanted to like be near you and I was
like oh that's a weird feeling because
it's not like I was in like a situation
with a bunch of strangers and you're the
only person I knew it so I was
gravitating towards you it was like you
and some of my best friends
yeah and I was like I just want to like
be next to Evan yeah yeah that's that's
a sign that's the same man like I was so
nervous I was like I was sweating over
here I was so nervous to tell you that I
liked you because we've been friends for
so long and you're an important like
five years if I told you that I liked
you and like it got awkward then that'd
be stubby so sad to like lose or like
make a really great friendship turn
awkward yeah so it's like telling you
that I liked you was like oh I was
stressed I was stressed but it was like
at the same time I wasn't stressed at
all ah
because yeah so did I told you I wasn't
stressed but like like changing like
flipping that switch you know like
opening that box yeah that was a nervous
thing for me I guess like by the time we
told each other and we told each other
like at the same time but I think by
then we knew yeah I think that we knew I
mean like we knew but you still nerve
nervous I was more nervous I was more
nervous to tell you that I liked you
then I was to ask you out or
to marry me we've chosen the ring
together like told our parents like yeah
we're just gonna you know like I think I
just need to be single for a little
while you know like and then we were
serious we're serious and then like a
month later I think we told each other
we liked each other yeah well it was
just like oh this is what a relationship
should be like yeah everything just
clicked
everything that's clicked everything
this was like oh this is natural this is
right this is how things should be for
me I mean it's it might be different for
every single person but for me and for
you our relationship was like in our
minds how relationships should work yeah
and it was just like the easiest switch
to make yeah you know what I mean yeah
and then like within a couple months we
were looking at rings I mean we actually
we did wait a while to actually get
married there cuz Alison do you wanted
like after proposing you know we waited
the decent map because he wanted to plan
yeah I'm Kaitlyn playing the whole whole
wedding and everything yeah I knew that
like I wouldn't want a wedding planner
one because I am changer
and two because like I'm a control freak
so going back to the story okay so I
told you that I liked you you told me
you liked me and then was it right then
that we had the long talk of everything
so we told each other we liked each
other in the morning and then right
afterwards we talked for like six hours
straight I don't wanna like keep on
exaggerating the number but I think it
was like seven those after lunch guys we
didn't eat breakfast we didn't eat lunch
we just chatted for a long time and if
you know us so it's like it's like we
don't really miss meals no I certainly
didn't so we just chatted we were like
you know what do you thing about kids
what do you think about religion what do
you think about like work-life balance
what do you think about like all the big
things that like could throw you for a
loop later on yeah and we told each
other every embarrassing story that
could come up yeah in the future it's
like these are like any deep dark
secrets that I have yeah all of the deep
dark
the two of us any embarrassing stories
that Caitlyn could be told I wanted to
tell her right off the bat so she's like
yeah I know about that you know so so we
we had that talk and then after that
point where I Wow
this is it yeah I don't know it was like
such I don't know it was just like uh it
was like we knew we knew yeah it's like
like I don't know this it's normal to
think about relationships as much as I
probably did throughout my life but I
always knew that a relationship the
relationship that I wanted would be more
important to me than any other choice in
my life in a way because that that's
more important than job that's
longer-lasting to your job that affects
like your kids in the future if you want
to have kids it's such a big decision
and I always was stressed out about how
do you know and then you just know it
seems super lame but it was just like Oh
everything's like just so easy I'm also
realizing that's how it is for us and
it's not the same for everyone yeah I
think for most people we've talked to
it's different yeah um but I think our
situation is also somewhat unique
because we were really good friends like
close friends for five years yeah and
since we were such close friends we
never kept not that like people
intentionally keep secrets from people
that they want to date but like I think
normally you like put your best foot
forward a little bit more when you're
like doing all of our like like nine
year old boy humor in front of each
other yeah I think that's most of our
story I mean you know we we dated
long-distance for a year almost yeah we
did and then finally I moved to Houston
we were in an apartment for a few months
we started DIY inge then because you
proposed when we were in the apartment
so we started DIY in stuff
the wedding I think the very first thing
we di wide ended up being what do we
wanna do we want it cuz I'm seeing that
we're about half an hour into the pod I
think let's just go for it let's just go
for it
do that and the game oh we can't do that
and a half long podcast games always
take like half an hour okay
we'll save the like early DIY stories
yeah for next time yeah I think we
should save it for next time okay and
now it's time for game show all right so
the game we're playing today is what we
call this one we didn't think of a good
name guess those lyrics read those
lyrics but you're not telling the person
to read them you're also those so one of
us is gonna read the lyrics in like a
straight faced way right okay just those
lyrics I think we're spending too much
time on that I'm alright first song so
here's here's here's the rules of the
game and you can play along each of us
is gonna take turns reading lyrics
without like you know trying to not do
like the inflection of the song and the
other person has to guess them so we've
each written down some lyrics to read to
the other person and you can play along
too and see if you think us all right
close your eyes okay I'm closing because
Evans playing oh I'm just not gonna look
I feel we are closing I try to read that
right let's each do - okay - that was
pretty good pretty good I am going to
pop some tags Oh harder one yeah
harder apart let's see if I can remember
it from my brain what do you know about
rocking a wolf on your noggin oh yeah I
would have done all right well that's
one
it starts with one thing I don't know
why give me another leg it doesn't even
matter
you know what threw me off huh
cuz in the song it's like it starts with
one and it's like it starts with one
thing I don't know why and you change it
you're like it starts with one thing
yeah you say it starts with one thing I
don't know why definitely you got to do
that's when you play the game right oh
I'm pretty good I know every word you do
okay don't look
I didn't so don't debate a player
straight you know he really doesn't get
it anyway he's gonna play the field and
keep it real for you no way for you no
way do I know the song yes I definitely
know the song yes it's not the chorus
well actually it well there's like I
don't know how to properly term songs
it's repeated in the song okay maybe a
second chorus do you want me to do
another yeah you do not okay you know
it's kind of hard just to get along
today our subject isn't cool but he
fakes it anyway he may not have a clue
and he may not have style but everything
[Laughter]
don't look and one pick another I think
I did it again
Benny's fears that doesn't has to be
and okay um go on now go walk out the
door just turn around now cuz you cannot
welcome any more give and go give a go
weren't you the one who tried to hurt me
with goodbye
I love the dramatic reading by the way
do you think I'd crumble did you think
I'd lay down and die no at first I was
afraid I only did two but yeah you can
go cuz you free oh no you're right I did
you three you got Brittany real faster
okay look at me we're unforgettable
daisy dukes bikinis on top Oh California
girls alright hello there the angel from
my nightmare the shadow the name of the
time
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right you can do it I believe in you
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah scooby mode to the left to the
left everything you own in a box to the
left I was thinking I was like to the
left to the left to the left or left to
the left to the right okay to the left
the left everything you own in a box
you're writing something I'm looking up
the rest of the ones really you could
guess it I mean if it's so obscure that
like you wouldn't even get it no I'm
like well I have no nothing I got it to
the left of the lot it to the right to
the left to the left everything you own
in the Box the left
no and you're even singing you know
what's another line that's the whole
song called um to the left that's the
song know your way into it let me get a
you could pack all your things we're
finished because you made your bed now
lie in it
I'll have another you by tomorrow don't
you ever think for a second get to
thinking you're irreplaceable I
literally have no idea really yeah do
you know it yeah I've listened to the
song before on the radio I was like
trying to pick up like popular pop songs
this is it's Beyonce irreplaceable hello
come on like you've listened to this no
this is new Beyonce no there's no way
there's literally no way I would guess
that I guess like to me sometimes when I
say to the left the song pops into my
head
I want twice to the left I want to say
it twice
see I just think of that wedding song
that like everyone plays at their
wedding to get people to actually start
dancing hopefully this wasn't covered I
just played it briefly one last one for
me well the last one for me mmm there's
vomit on his sweater already mom's
spaghetti
[Laughter]
I've often dreamed of a far off place
we're great warm welcome will be waiting
for me Oh mom wanna know what no okay
given gone do this from the movie yes it
is from a movie can I go where the
crowds will cheer Oh Hercules
oh you can't sing too much more that was
a good one thank you I'm really excited
for when we like play like movie I'm so
excited for that one okay do you have
time to listen to me whine about nothing
and everything all at once you're good
at like changing the tone and like the
pacing I'm one of those melodramatic
fools neurotic to the bone no doubt
about it no doubt no I will say I was
listening to no doubt and this band at
the same time in my life okay keep on
going cuz I right now I'm falling it was
nothing okay I'm pulling a blank right
here I'll take a different well I guess
this does come after but um sometimes I
give myself the creeps
Oh creep no I use the word tricks on me
oh come on I know this one Oh give me a
go okay okay I don't know like ruin the
game I'm not like a cheater
what does not impress me of I mean
excuse me it all keeps adding up I think
I'm cracking up like this sounds
familiar now sing a little bit of it do
you have the time too
[Laughter]
no vain the name of the song isn't in
the lyrics um their name the name of the
band has a color in it that's the same
clothes okay okay was that three I think
it was 200 you do one more
I do Hercules in I did green game okay I
stay out too late got nothing in my
brain that's what people say
mmm-hmm that's what people say mmm-hmm
you from Gong's was that like the really
iconic part it was a very beginning of
the song I mean I can't do the iconic
part it's literally two iconic it's two
iconic okay that's the backup option
that's nuclear option uh okay I can try
it I can even keep going or I can okay
hmm I go on too many dates but I can't
make them stay at least that's what
people say this like grow up they grow
up fun Yeah right no no that was part of
the lyrics that's what people say mm-hmm
is this like what's my age again no no
it's a lot newer than that okay I'll try
a different part um my ex-man brought
his new girlfriend she's like oh my god
but I'm just gonna shake it shake it
shake it shake it no
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but different sections of song there's a
lot of different sections in the song
and you should be able to use your
context clues to know well okay but I
keep cruising can't stop won't stop
grooving
are you sure I've listened to the song
yes it's like I got those music in my
mind saying it's gonna be alright
I'm not gonna latch on it's gonna be
alright
it's GEX that's not it okay I'm gonna
get okay
no the iconic part mm cause the players
gonna play because the players gonna
play play fake it off I don't know those
lyrics got nothing on my brain my
girlfriend bought her new girlfriend
yeah I wouldn't have gotten it even if
you had have sung that part well cause
the players gonna play let me minimize
this and then
I uh I've been choosing the iconic parts
too early
yeah give me some hard yeah cuz like I
think I'm too good yeah cause like I
shouldn't have led with like like mom's
spaghetti
oh no that was pretty awesome because
like ya didn't give me the opportunity
to yell mom spaghetti I would have been
disappointed I have just like the iconic
lire written down yeah it's
caitlin is playing it in hard mode hard
mode - like doing the first doing either
the chorus or the beginning of the song
both of those should be easy
hmm let's see you can test it on me all
right I mean you can start with
something harder like a more obscure
part hmm this is such a repetitive song
any part of it is like the same more
obscure part okay I met a girl down at
the disco
she's a minute girl down at the Disco's
she said hey hey hey hey let's go milk
was Fergie's group Black Eyed Peas
I'm a girl down at the disco she said
hey hey hey hey let's go what are you
gonna do with all that junk inside of
your trunk see it's harder it's harder
have you started with what you're gonna
do with all that junk I like totally
would have gone totally yeah yeah that
was a good part to start with you don't
have to feel like a waste of space Oh
firework can I was gonna start with do
you feel like a plastic bag how did you
get it with like you don't have to feel
like a waste of space I would have never
got you know cuz you're good at this
okay fellas that's all I got you like
blew through mine way too fast okay I
got a few more for you okay give me two
more and we can end on like my stumble
okay okay next time I'm gonna go on
hardmode for you you can go over how you
got me able to let one song that Beyonce
won oh yeah that's because you like
haven't listened to it too much I didn't
get in your head like to the left to the
left
I mean that's the only lyric I know
song but it's stuck in there mmm buddy
you're a boy make a big noise playin in
the street gonna be a big man someday
disguise
I'm sure if you sung that to me I would
have got it oh you would totally get it
okay I'm gonna start with another I
can't do the next line I feel like
you're good you'll know it buddy they're
gonna be a big boy one day okay buddy
you're you're an old man poor man
pleading with your eyes I'm gonna get
you some peace some day let me do
another one
the name of the song is buddy nope bye
buddy buddy buddy you're a young man
hard man shouting in the street okay
gonna take on the world some day young
man that six in my head a little bit
Oh YMCA know you've got blood on your
face big disgrace done a net dad that
dinner end yeah I knew and I said big
disgrace your blood on your face you'd
get up will rock you okay um you did
that one pretty good wait wait wait wait
oh I was like I did a queen bohemian you
got it second so hard thing is we did a
lot of the same artists we do that a lot
I know we have like very similar it
sounds like you did thrift shop I did
thrift shop you did fryer work I did
find work yeah well okay here's here's
one that isn't an artist you've done I
still hear your voice when you sleep
next to me I still just go to touch in
my dreams forgive me my weakness but I
don't know why that Dada Dada Dada Dada
Dada it's like it's like like
techno techno something without you it's
hard to survive without you I know this
I know this this is the part where I
start punching the air an excitement hey
can you can you can be sorry with the
first word again I still hear your voice
I still hear your voice yeah gosh it's
like right there me my weakness dad dad
dad already go five go on and survive
it's like everytime we touch we rock out
of this in the past it's like like I'm
gonna do one more song yeah I'm bad at
remembering stuff you know you did
you're doing better than I thought how
bad do you think I was gonna do okay I
never made it as a wise man I couldn't
cut it as a poor man stealing I'm tired
there's a creed or something like this
of living like a blind man I'm sick of
sight without a sense of seeing don't
just squeeze the clamp on our table
no okay so the first words you said like
got me like I was like I know this song
dude again I will say those are the
first words oh okay which so that proves
my argument that chorus or first words
alright so what was the very first words
never made it never made it as a wise
man couldn't cut it
yes I am
if I do the voice it might help let me
do another part another part I know it's
like an exaggerated ridiculous voice
it's like it's like something like do
the voice do you think it is before it
give it away
it's like Creed right or it's not
creeping like it's not great couldn't go
ahead man something like exaggeratedly
like like something you are kind of
you're wrong but you're not wrong on the
right track you're you're you're wrong
cuz that's not actually a different way
but you're not wrong because that's how
I sing some of the more iconic part it
supposed to be a singing contest of
lyrics it's like crazy Levon cream are
we having fun yet yeah yeah yeah no no
yeah yeah yeah no no are we having fun
yet yeah yeah yeah yeah no no actually
yes what those are the lyrics that
someone wrote yeah yeah yeah no no no no
yeah yeah yes I mean yeah yeah yeah no
no yeah yeah yeah no no okay that's how
you remind me right yes who was the
artist that's how to wrap it up guys
that's around like we can like hit it
even better to the next time around yeah
I think like like we can refine it cuz I
feel a little bit more challenging yeah
yeah and you can be a little bit easier
on me you were out a good level yeah
we're good but I do need to find more
variety and artists because I skipped
over a lot of fine because you had
already done
artists well I what I need to do is I
think I need to find like a song that I
know you've listened to but that has a
lot of lyrics that just like get lost
yeah yeah it'd be a good test how do you
good test okay well hey back includes
today's podcast so much for joining us
this is some fun oh wait we still have a
few more things so well here first I'll
give like a really quick medical updates
and since I told you guys about like
things last week I've talked to three
different doctors three different
diagnoses or opinions so I'm going in to
get more tests about things and I'll
just give you guys updates when there's
something more to report besides my
doctors are disagreeing and I need to
get more tests yeah more sure about what
we thought was going on we talked to
another doctor he's like well I don't
know yeah so instead of like just like
like continually giving you like my
doctor's opinions which like oh okay two
doctors said something I think that it's
this and then like gosh anyways moving
on that's where we're at and if anything
changes we'll keep you guys posted but
other than that it's just waiting on
health care the downsides about owning
your own business as health care is a
little extra difficult yeah I mean we
have it we have it yeah there's more
hoops and we're paying a lot more than
we used to when we had normal jobs
that's the true thing yeah all right
things of the week you know the week so
okay so my thing of the week I'm super
excited about because I don't know why I
haven't mentioned it earlier it's one of
my most used tools of all the tools that
I have this is chill between woodworking
3d printing like CAD work like
everything everything I do I almost
always use this and it's my digital
calipers you don't even need to get like
super precise like plus or minus point
zero zero one thousandths or anything
just get some like just get a good set
of digital calipers like eight inches is
a good middle ground six inches is a
little bit too short so like a pair you
like yeah cuz like like those
my opinion in the past is to get a
really nice big one but then you don't
have it with you and it's less
convenient so I think like an 8 inch is
just the right middle ground I'll put a
link down below to like a good one
that's good enough that's high-quality
about cheap enough that like you're
gonna use it not worry about it yeah
yeah um so my thing of the week is a
video I'm sure a lot of you guys know
Jesse Wade a venue ATIS sister she did a
awesome video where she took rogue
weights and turned them into a battle ax
and it's all like Game of Thrones themed
and like the costumes and the music she
she did all the music she made the
costumes the whole video is so freaking
epic it's just so awful so cool like it
sucks you in and you feel like you're
watching a movie it's so in the build
itself is super awesome super holding
the whole video is stylized and it's
really cool and then she got to give it
to the mountain at the end of the video
drones yeah and and I want to mention
she she made it like like Brett McAfee
from school Slade was also in there and
he has his own video that we haven't
watched that we're excited a while we're
excited to ask that so we can put that
we and pull a bob and put that on our
like we haven't watched this yet but I
think it's gonna be good because he
makes really good video see but we've
only watched as he's about like knowing
the amount of work she put into that
also made it so much more epic she like
like figured out how to play piano just
so that she could play it she already
knew how to play the violin or some
string instrument so she already knew
how to do that so she played that part
but then she went she needed to put p
annum you're some sort other sort of
music in there so she learned an entire
musical instrument so that she could
record a song so it didn't get copy
strip stricken and taken down so she
recorded her own music for it just so
that she could like include that iconic
music in her thing that's like that's
some good yeah it's an awesome awesome
video awesome awesome video yeah yeah
and with that I think that ends the
podcast episode thank you guys again for
everyone who's been
listening and sharing and leaving
reviews I think that Windows is going up
let's go so so this coming Friday we're
gonna be releasing the video where we
show off how we made this whole podcast
thing yeah if you're interested in how
we're running this podcast check out
that video and we're also gonna be
announcing that we have a podcast in a
more broader way on our YouTube channel
and everything so hopefully that can
like maybe boost us in the chart so if
you really want to like help us make a
push to see how high we can get on
iTunes charts we've gone to nine let's
see if we can get past or higher than
nine I know so maybe maybe like between
Friday and the the Monday after the
podcast video okay this your help to
spread the word about this podcast yeah
[Music]
yes he was a barrier Oh have I ever
mentioned that you have perfect pitch
perfect perfect so good